Mit Aromahopfen und speziellen Hefen
will die Industrie das perfekte
alkoholfreie Bier entwickelt haben.
Sebastian Lege wirft einen Blick in
den Braukessel und testet,
ob ein Trachtenverein das alkoholfreie
Bier herausschmecken kann.
Zünftig im Brauhaus trifft Lege die
Bierfreunde der Trachtengruppe Augsburg.
Normalerweise kommt bei ihnen nur
Gerstensaft mit Prozenten ins Glas.
Aber werden sie auch in einer Blindverkostung alkoholfreie Biere von normalen unterscheiden können?
Sebastian Lege macht den Test.
Er serviert sechs verschiedene Biere,
davon nur drei mit Alkohol.
Und tatsächlich: Zielsicher identifizieren
unsere Tester die Alkoholfreien.
SEBASTIAN: "Und? Schmeckt es?"
TESTERIN: "Das schmeckt nicht gut."
TESTER: "Da ist kein Alkohol drin."
"Schmecken tut's auch nicht."
"Um Gottes Willen."
TESTERIN: "Nicht bayerntauglich."
TESTERIN 2: "Wässrig im Abgang."
Wer alkoholfreies Bier braut, steht vor einer Herausforderung.
Das deutsche Reinheitsgebot erlaubt als Zutaten
nur Wasser, Gerste, Hopfen und Hefe.
Künstliche Aromen oder zugesetzte Geschmacksverstärker sind tabu.
Im normalen Bier aber verstärkt der
Alkohol die natürlichen Aromen.
Gleiche Zutaten, aber weniger Alkohol.
Traditionell wird bei der Herstellung
von alkoholfreiem Bier die Hefe stark
gekühlt, damit sie weniger Alkohol freisetzt.
Und während die Gärung von normalem
Bier eine ganze Woche dauert,
wird sie beim alkoholfreien schon
nach einem Tag gestoppt.
Das ergibt statt 5 Prozent nur 0,5 Prozent Alkohol.
Die Hefezellen im normalen Bier setzen
während der einen Woche Gärzeit
aber nicht nur alkoholfrei, sondern auch
reichlich Aromastoffe.
Davon entstehen bei der Kühl- und
Kurzgärung deutlich weniger.
Die Alternative: Man nimmt normales Bier
und entfernt den Alkohol durch Destillation.
Doch auch hier geht Aroma flöten.
Am Ende hat man ein Bier mit 0 Prozent Alkohol.
Um die Aromaverluste auszugleichen, setzen einige Hersteller wie das Brauhaus Riegele
auf verschiedene Tricks.
Aber was genau tun sie, damit ihr Alkoholfreies wirklich mit alkoholhaltigen Bieren mithalten kann?
Sebastian Lege will sich das vor
Ort mal genauer anschauen.
SEBASTIAN: "So, jetzt geht's los."
Am Anfang steht wie bei jedem
Bier ein Sud aus Gerstenmalz.
Je mehr Malz, desto mehr Alkohol
entsteht später bei der Gärung.
Deshalb lautet der erste Trick: Es kommt
gerade so viel Malz in den Kessel,
dass es Würze gibt und nur ganz wenig Alkohol.
Und dann kommt die Seele des Bieres: der Hopfen!
Reich an Bitterstoffen und den wildesten
Aromen, schwärmt Hopfenbauer Wittmann.
WITTMANN: "Wenn man hier riecht, riecht man Holunder, Blaubeeren, bisschen Ananas, Zitrus."
"Also aus diesem Hopfen kann man Biere
brauen, die dann sehr toll schmecken."
Über 20 Hopfensorten werden
in Deutschland angebaut.
Traditionsbrauer aber setzen auf bewährtes und
ändern möglichst wenig an ihrer Rezeptur.
Doch fehlt der Geschmacksträger Alkohol im Bier kann,
das nur ein spezieller Aromahopfen ausgleichen.
SEBASTIAN: "Boah, das riecht ja echt wahnsinn!"
"Was ist das für Hopfen?"
BRAUER: "Das ist ein Mittelfrüh."
"Das sind Hopfen-Pellets. Das ist ein Aromahopfen."
Weil diese Sorte anfälliger für Krankheiten und damit teurer im Anbau war, geriet sie in Vergessenheit.
Doch dank ihres besonders würzigen
Aromas erlebt sie nun ein Comeback.
SEBASTIAN: "Ich schmeiss es einfach rein?
Aber ohne Glas natürlich." - "Bitte, ja!"
SEBASTIAN: "Miraculix würzt seine Suppe... . Fertig!"
Aber es gibt noch eine Zutate, die entscheidet, ob das Alkoholfreie schmeckt wie ein Echtes. Die Hefe!
Sie verwandelt das Malz in Alkohol und sorgt für
den unverwechselbaren Biergeschmack.
Genau hier wendet die Industrie
deshalb ihren wichtigsten Trick an.
Mikrobiologen tüfteln an speziellen Hefekulturen.
Die produzieren nur wenig Alkohol, dafür
aber besonders ausgeprägte Aromen.
Das Arsenal der Züchter ist enorm. Manche Hefen sorgen für fruchtige oder exotische Noten.
Der Clou: Hefen mit Minzaromen, die sich im Mund leicht scharf anfühlen - wie Alkohol eben.
Doch ein Prozent Restalkohol ist immer noch zu viel.
Die Lösung: Es wird jetzt so viel
0,0 Prozent Bier beigemischt,
bis die gesetzlich geforderten
0,5 Prozent unterschritten werden.
Beim Wein ist so ein Sortenverschnitt
als Cuvée schon lange üblich.
Für Biertrinker noch ziemlich gewagt.
Aber am Schluss zählt nur, ob sich die
Mühen gelohnt haben.
Der Härtetest: Halten die Augsburger
Bierfreunde das Stöffchen in der
Blindverkostung für ein Bier
mit oder ohne Alkohol?
TESTERIN: "Das ist mit."
SEBASTIAN: "Und?" - "Ja, schmeckt."
TESTERIN: "Mit."
"Und schmeckt's?"
TESTERIN: "Das ist in Ordnung."
"Alkoholfrei, das schmeckt mir nicht."
TESTER: "Joah, die ext das auch gleich weg."
Na also, geht doch!
Alkoholfreie Biere holen geschmacklich
auf - dank neuer innovativer Brautricks.
Inzwischen setzen viele Marken auf
Hightech-Hefen und Superhopfen.
Selbst die hippe Craft-Beer-Szene
erfrischt sich mit alkoholfreien Ales.
Und einige entschärfte Weizenbiere
überzeugten sogar die Stiftung Warentest.
Gut auch für Figurbewusste, denn sie
enthalten rund 40 Prozent weniger Kalorien
als die alkoholhaltige Konkurrenz.
Na dann Prost!
Schmeckt euch alkoholfreies Bier?
Sagt es uns in den Kommentaren!
Ihr seid eher Weinliebhaber, dann zeigt euch Sebastian, worauf ihr beim Kauf achten solltet!
Und wollt ihr noch mehr über euer Essen wissen,
dann abonniert die ZDFbesseresser
und schaut woher das TK-Gemüse kommt!